o protagonismo também estado
da vida e eu não programei planejei está
aqui com vocês
não planejei ser chineiro feliz chineiro
não programei cerac teto ea minha
família também não pagou os meus pais
viva o brasil em 1931 meu tio veio
sozinho pra essa terra chamada para dir
utah descobrir como é que era essa terra
e as condições dos imigrantes japoneses
nesse intercâmbio brasil japão em poucos
meses ele já tinha uma clara opinião
mandou ates meu pai no japão e dizendo
não venho que é fria
só que o ato se na época era de 1 e não
as há
levou quase um mês para chegar e aí meu
pai e sua família já estava em direção
ao brasil e chega a família jackson no
japão no brasil e junto com a família
veio a cultura e junto com essa cultura
tem três símbolos para dividir com vocês
que fazem parte da minha vida
o prêmio primeiro símbolo é o max ou
camon que o símbolo da família e os
outros dois símbolos é uma expressão que
a primeira enron e t ball pessoal não é
cerveja mas quer dizer japão sempre
sempre em primeiro lugar ea segunda
expressão é o gambare muitos que foram a
olimpíada de 2012 e janeiro viram essa
frase
o estímulo é sacrifício é garra até o
seu limite a combinação destes dois
símbolos fez a minha direção acadêmica
meus pais eram davam prioridade para a
formação acadêmica e eles eram muito
democráticos tinham seis profissões para
eu seguir
a primeira era medicina clássica a
segunda a medicina a terceira a medicina
ea e variável de engenharia depois
engenharia e por último a bendita
engenheiro e então como não sou muito
simpática sangue seguia a engenharia
deus na véspera de fazer meu vestibular
o cursinho pré-vestibular um primo meu
gênio resolve em trem entre os primeiros
lugares nas três importantíssimo as
escolas faculdade de engenharia do
brasil conseguindo ita fez o pole fei e
o ita
diante desse cenário essa pressão do
unión e de barriga bar e eu vivi tô
ferrado
imagina eu vou ficar para trás e muito
imagina engenharia
muitos colegas rita unir graças a deus
que ele sabe como eu sou em causa mas aí
que aconteceu entrou arquitetura e aí
fui pro curso de arquitetura e no curso
de arquitetura era uma loucura não sei
como é que é hoje mas era um bullying
coletivo dos professores alunos fazem de
tudo pra gente gravava aprender é é
decorar e esse contra o olímpico em roma
tiba eu ganhar e eu resolvi fazer
caricaturas dos professores é claro
e aí numa manhã cinzenta
de garoa paulistana me chama um lugar
muito conhecido no histórico popular é
do meu scoop histórico escolar que era a
diretoria
chegando lá tinha um professor
proprietário do cursinho caricatura dele
e ele perguntou você fez essa acusação
eu confirmo que sim aí ele começou a
olhar pra mim começou a sorrir que eu
não entendi nada
sendo que a fazer as caricaturas da capa
do jornal do cursinho estou precisando
de chamar atenção e você vai ganhar por
isso que isso é uma coisa tão absurda e
aí eu falei tá bom eu comecei a fazer as
caricaturas a capa ganhava até pra pagar
o cursinho e aí o que aconteceu é que é
uma coisa gostosa ser reconhecido pelos
colegas e principalmente pelas colegas
sentiu o máximo mas veio o desconforto
como é que eu poderia cobrar por algo
que eu nasci fazia com amor com prazer
rápido e ainda comprar mas esse
desconforto passou quando eu descobri
que poderia sim ter prazer com trabalho
difícil
comecei conseguiu crea formou em
arquitetura e conseguiu o conselho
regional de arquitetura e engenharia e
agronomia
minha paixão sempre foi pra ilustração
caricatura e também comunicação visual
hoje tem um apelido e que é design
gráfico na época era isso e continue
assim que eu virei um cartunista um
comunicador visol e ilustrador continuei
fazendo minhas caricaturas será mais uma
revista
shalom na época e também fazia e pintura
de ônibus logotipo e esse ônibus
circulou muito aqui no sul
logotipo de ônibus
e eu também fazia personalizar a noção
de moto que eu desenvolvi uma técnica
que hoje faz indicou ter cortado as
máscaras para pintar a mão e fazer essa
costura chama café racer mas na época
fazia isso e também com a paixão de duas
rodas
eu comecei a andar voltando na minha
história com três anos de idade já
andava com bicicleta de de duas rodas e
aos 10 anos eu já andava com bicicleta
já adulto e também tão precoce que eu
comecei a contar até 4 na minha mão
direita por um acidente de bicicleta mas
hoje todo mundo acha que eu sou da
'máfia japonesa a yakuza seguir fazendo
as caricaturas e aí ilustrações eu fiz
um catálogo por uma pequena perfumaria
da vila madalena que era 360 graus o
catálogo girava porque tinha um pouco o
portfólio e ele não tinha capa e
contracapa ele tinha só caco então essa
é um lado e outro era esse e foi um
sucesso ela era uma assessora de
comunicação de uma grande empresa do rio
grande do sul
e gostou do trabalho falou o presidente
está procurando está entrevistando
design projeto sigiloso como eu gosto de
sigilos o curioso é que o avião foi para
porto alegre subir 110 quilômetros pra
farroupilha na serra gaúcha e tive a
reunião e descobri que o presidente está
procurando o produto alternativo
alcançado eu acho porque o que ele
estava sentindo aqui depois do grande
sucesso no final dos anos 70 e até os
meados de 80 o sucesso estava terminando
e ele precisava de otimizar suas
máquinas injetoras de plástico
ok fui para são paulo e diante do filme
e te descobri que as meninas brigavam e
acho que é o empoderamento já começava
aquela época
mann e brigava com os meninos pra andar
com bicicleta a quarta vez que até deles
e na época existiam bicicleta para
menino e bicicleta pra menina então aí a
proposta nasceu da bicicleta perfumada
decorrer dentada grafitada prontos chão
os vestidos e tudo e projeto foi
aprovado esse aqui é um pouco a polaroid
uma dos poucos registros de sobá da
época
e aí é é a apareceu apreciam uma um
chinelo de gás pela de tira larga e ele
pediu para desenvolver ver essa tira e
eu fiz atira a embalagem display
entreguei depois de alguns meses o
presidente ou eu vi em farroupilha que o
produto estava vendendo todo mundo
estava otimista desenvolver três tiras
largas coloquei numa gaveta e continuei
com a minha bicicleta
uma semana depois o presidente chegou e
veio perguntar sobre se eu poderia fazer
mais uma tira lhe apresente as três
tiras largas e nesse momento me olhou e
falou vem comigo desenvolver calçado e
esqueça a bicicleta neste momento disse
não posso ir porque senão pode porque
você contatou fazer bicicleta
eu não sei nada de calçado aliás não sei
até hoje
mas ele disse olha pessoal gostou de ti
vai te ensinar italiana seguir fazendo a
bicicleta e assim a bicicleta foi
diminuindo e assim eu virei um chinelo
de plástico
foi aí que foi o primeiro projeto de uma
prancha de 85 correndo porque eu
esse projeto se esse aqui é nada é em 89
acredite se quiser só aquele sentado na
ponta oriental no meio dos dois outros
colegas
a gente era tão pequeno tão pequena que
a gente escolheu para ser grande no
carrinho em bolonha assim
depois com o tempo eu fui crescendo
presenciado por várias marcas de uma
marca em 1988 é eu tinha uma marca que
eu era fã já pelo seu lado contestador
seu lado lúdico seu lado colorido ao
pastoral e muito longe do sapato
convencional e aí eu fui apresentar com
a marca que hoje é uma referência
mundial
e ela é sinônimo de categoria dentro da
cultura japonesa do gambari e do nippon
e tiba é claro que minha mãe meu pai
sempre sonhei que eu casasse com uma
gueixa
mas como sou do contra sou diferente
casei com uma italiana da serra gaúcha a
sofia e hoje eu ando de espaço atrás
dela nascer os dois já paulinho pedro
hoje mas isso cresce véu e agora família
mas o chute é essa é a família e hoje em
2016 este ano recebeu um presente
maravilhoso tática do time que eu faço
parte que foi um presente uma surpresa
maravilhosa
lembra que eu tinha só polaroid ganhei
bicicleta um protótipo com uma base de
todas assinada das pessoas da equipe
isso pra mim foi um presente maravilhoso
bicicleta que não conseguiu fazer a
equipe e hoje eu faço parte de um grande
time de erechim o time dos sonhos
espalhadas pelo brasil e pelo mundo e
entre os presentes maior foi o presente
enquanto com oscar minha mãe a seu
escritório em copacabana foi pra
convidar um projeto colaborativo e o
presente veio em forma de uma frase a
vida minha pronta cada coisa agora ela
vê e aparece com o saldo plástico
projetar eu na hora pensei se o rio o
choro mas não chorei porque eu chorei de
ver aquele ser humano com uma extrema
uma experiência vasta os 101 anos o
dobro da minha idade ainda aberto para o
que a vida lhe oferecia
hoje eu sinto que eu sou o suficiente e
quero chegar comune é maior 100 anos e
que a vida minha pronta ea própria mundo
abrindo possibilidades que eu acolherei
com muito amor amor próprio e amor ao
próximo
bem-vindo à deriva da vida ary gatto